DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
FROM THE AMERICAN MUSEUM OF
NATURAL HISTORY IN
NEW YORK CITY, AND BEAMING
OUT ACROSS ALL OF SPACE
AND TIME, THIS IS STARTALK,
WHERE SCIENCE AND
POP CULTURE COLLIDE.
WELCOME TO THE HALL
OF THE UNIVERSE.
RIGHT HERE IN NEW YORK CITY.
I AM NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON,
YOUR PERSONAL ASTROPHYSICIST,
AND TONIGHT WE ARE FEATURING
MY INTERVIEW WITH THE ONE,
THE ONLY, THE AMERICAN
LEGEND, THE HERO, BUZZ ALDRIN.
BUZZ ALDRIN, PILOT OF THE
APOLLO 11 MISSION TO THE MOON.
SO LET'S DO THIS.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE].
I NEVER DO THIS ALONE,
AND I'VE GOT MY PROFESSIONAL
COMEDIAN CO-HOST
ILIZA SHLESINGER.
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
ILIZA, WELCOME, WELCOME.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: THANK YOU.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: AND I,
I ALSO HAVE A PERSON WHOSE WHO'S
ACTUALLY BEEN INTO SPACE.
THE ONE AND ONLY,
MIKE MASSIMINO, MIKE.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE].
WELCOME BACK TO STARTALK.
MIKE MASSIMINO: GREAT,
GREAT TO BE HERE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND MIKE MASSIMINO,
YOU'RE ONE OF MY FAVORITE
ASTRONAUTS EVER BECAUSE YOU
HELPED TO FIX THE
HUBBLE SPACE TELESCOPE.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
I DID, YEP, THANK YOU.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YEAH, THAT'S NOT AN.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: COME ON.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND YOU WERE NOT ONLY JUST
ONE OF THE MANY
MISSIONS THAT FIXED IT.
YOU ARE THE LAST
MISSION TO FIX IT.
MIKE MASSIMINO: THAT'S RIGHT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND THAT'S THE ONE THAT WAS
AT HIGHEST RISK OF FAILURE.
MIKE MASSIMINO: RIGHT WE
WERE, UH, SINCE WE WERE THE
LAST ONES THERE WAS NO ONE
ELSE TO CLEAN UP OUR MESS.
WE HAD TO GET IT RIGHT.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: AFTER YOU
FIXED IT DID YOU WALK OFF LIKE,
"I FIXED IT GOOD?"
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YEAH, YEAH.
MIKE MASSIMINO: NO WAIT, I WAS,
ILIZA, IT WAS MORE LIKE,
"I HOPE I FIXED IT GOOD."
AND NOW, AND NOW APPARENTLY,
WHAT NEIL'S SAYING IT DOES WORK.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YEAH IT WORKS, IT WORKS.
YEAH, IT'S OUR PEOPLE,
I, I GOT FULL REPORTS,
YOU DID A GOOD JOB.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
THANK YOU, GOOD TO HEAR.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: SO
BUZZ ALDRIN CAME THROUGH TOWN
AND I JUST HAD TO NAB
HIM FOR AN INTERVIEW.
HE AND I GO WAY BACK.
SO IT WAS, IT WAS A FRIEND,
FRIENDLY, UH LIKE OLD TIMES.
AND, SO HE, HE
CAME TO MY OFFICE.
AND I WANTED TO KNOW HOW
DID HE BECOME THE GUY TO
GO TO THE MOON.
NOT EVERY ASTRONAUT
GOES TO THE MOON.
NOT EVERY PERSON
BECOMES AN ASTRONAUT.
SO LET'S CHECK IT OUT.
BUZZ ALDRIN: I WAS IN THE
SAME SQUADRON WITH ED WHITE.
SUPERSONIC F100S IN GERMANY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
ED WHITE WHO WAS ON APOLLO 1.
BUZZ ALDRIN: THAT'S RIGHT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WE LOST HIM.
BUZZ ALDRIN: AND HE LEFT UH,
HE GOT ME INTO THE SQUADRON.
THEN HE LEFT AND UH WENT
THROUGH THE TEST PILOT SCHOOL.
THAT QUALIFIED HIM TO
UH BE TESTING AIRPLANES.
SO A LITTLE LATER,
HE CALLED ME UP AND SAID UH,
IN SIXTY-TWO NOW I'M AT UH MIT
AND HE SAYS,
"NASA'S LOOKING FOR ANOTHER
GROUP OF ASTRONAUTS."
AND UH,
I'M QUALIFIED.
AND UH, I, I THINK I'LL APPLY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
ANOTHER GROUP AFTER
THE MERCURY 7.
BUZZ ALDRIN: THAT'S RIGHT,
THE FIRST ONES
AFTER THE SECOND ONE.
UM, AND I SAID,
"ED, I CAN SHOOT GUNNERY
BETTER THAN YOU CAN."
AND BESIDES THAT, I'M,
I'M STUDYING UH FOR MY
DOCTORS DEGREE HERE.
AND I'VE DECIDED TO UH,
JOIN UP DOING THIS IN SPACE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
DOCKING?
BUZZ ALDRIN: NO.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
NOT DOCKING?
BUZZ ALDRIN: YOU CAN'T
DOCK UNTIL YOU RENDEZVOUS.
YOU GOT TO LAUNCH.
YOU GOT TO MAKE A
COUPLE OF MANEUVERS.
THEN YOU CAN RENDEZVOUS.
IT'S LIKE A FIGHTER PILOT,
UH SHOOTING DOWN THE OTHER GUY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
TWO MOVING BODIES THAT
HAVE TO INTERSECT, YES.
BUZZ ALDRIN: THAT,
THIS IS BRINGING ONE ON A,
WHAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
BE A PERFECT TRAJECTORY.
BECAUSE YOU'VE LOOKED AT
IT AND IT'S JUST THE ONE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YOU'VE STUDIED THAT?
BUZZ ALDRIN:
I DID IT, I DID IT.
[NEIL LAUGHING].
BEFORE AND AFTER,
SHOOTING DOWN A COUPLE OF
MIGS IN KOREA.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO MIKE HOW MANY MIGS
DID YOU SHOOT DOWN BEFORE
YOU BECAME AN ASTRONAUT?
MIKE MASSIMINO:
UH, ZERO. YEAH, NO.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
ALRIGHT, SO WE GOT A LITTLE
SLICE OF
THE RIGHT STUFF THERE.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH,
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT,
THAT'S A DIFFERENT, YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO, HE WAS IN THE KOREAN WAR,
SHOT DOWN MIGS AND
HE WAS BORN IN 1930 SO
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN THE AGE
IN THAT ERA TO DO THAT.
AND SO HERE WE ARE
DRAWING FROM THIS POPULATION
TO REPRESENT US IN SPACE.
MIKE MASSIMINO: RIGHT,
YEAH, AND BACK THEN THEY WERE
ALL UH MILITARY TEST PILOTS.
AND WHEN THE SHUTTLE ERA
CAME IN 1978 THEY HAD A,
A GROUP OF, OF ASTRONAUTS
THAT WERE STILL THE,
THE MILITARY TEST PILOTS,
BUT YOU HAD THE
FIRST ASTRONAUTS OF COLOR,
THE FIRST WOMEN
WHO ARE ASTRONAUTS.
AND YOU HAD A LOT OF
SCIENTISTS AND ENGINEERS.
WE STILL HAVE MILITARY PEOPLE,
WE STILL HAVE TEST PILOTS.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE...
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
ACADEMIC.
MIKE MASSIMINO: MEN AND WOMEN,
LIKE ME WHO ARE ACADEMICS.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
ACADEMICS, YOU HAVE A PHD
IN ENGINEERING.
MIKE MASSIMINO: CORRECT,
A PHD IN ENGINEERING AND WE
HAVE MEDICAL DOCTORS,
AND SCIENTISTS, AND PEOPLE
FROM ALL PARTS OF LIFE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO BUZZ, YOU KNOW.
HE WAS, HE LANDED ON THE,
IT WAS THE FIRST MISSION TO,
TO LAND ON THE MOON.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SECOND TO WALK ON THE MOON.
UH HE, HAD, HAD
HIS PHD BY THEN.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: AND IT SEEMS
HE GOT A GOLD RING FOR EACH
ONE OF THOSE ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: IT
LOOKS THAT HE'S BLINGED OUT.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH, YEAH,
HE'S, HE'S GOT A LOT OF RINGS.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: HE'S
WEARING MORE RINGS THAN I AM.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
MY BOY IS BLING, OKAY.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH,
HE'S BIG ON THE JEWELRY.
AND THAT WAS JUST
A SAMPLE I THINK.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: IT WAS
A TRUNK'S, A TRUNK SHOW.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
OKAY, SO HE WAS ALSO THE FIRST
TO TRAIN UNDERWATER TO
SIMULATE WEIGHTLESSNESS.
MIKE MASSIMINO: THAT
WAS HIS IDEA ACTUALLY.
HE WAS A SCUBA DIVER
AND BEFORE HIS UH,
HIS SPACEWALKING ADVENTURE
HIS, HIS MISSION IN GEMINI.
THEY HAD TROUBLE SPACEWALKING
ON, ON THE GEMINI MISSIONS.
AND UH GENE CERNAN
ENDED UP BEING THE LAST
PERSON ON THE MOON
DURING HIS SPACEWALK ON
THE GEMINI MISSIONS.
HE FOGGED OVER HIS
HELMET AND HAD TROUBLE
GETTING BACK INSIDE.
MIKE MASSIMINO: AND THEY
DIDN'T REALLY HAVE A WAY TO,
IT'S, IT'S INTERESTING
TO HEAR THESE GUYS TALK ABOUT
HOW THEY SPACEWALKED IN.
THEY JUST WERE,
JUST WINGING IT.
AND BUZZ WAS THE FIRST GUY
TO PUT SOME SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERING BEHIND IT.
AND PUT WATER
RESTRAINING IN THE WATER.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
HE, HE SPACED WALKED FOR
FIVE AND HALF HOURS.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH,
HE HAD ALL KINDS OF,
HE HAD THINGS LIKE RESTRAINTS,
AND HAND, AND HANDRAILS.
AND HOW TO USE YOUR TETHERS.
AND HOW TO TRAIN FOR IT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO HE THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
HE WAS AN ACADEMIC.
HE SAID, "I DON'T
KNOW HOW THIS WORKS;
LET ME FIGURE IT OUT."
MIKE MASSIMINO:
RIGHT, AND HE, HE CAME UP
WITH THAT IDEA, BUZZ DID.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND AS, AS WE'VE SAID BEFORE,
HE'S RECENTLY WRITTEN A
BOOK, COLLECTING HIS MOST UH
PROFOUND MOMENTS IN SPACE.
SO I ASKED HIM ABOUT THEM.
CHECK IT OUT.
WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE
STORY THAT YOU TELL IN HERE
THAT YOU WANT
THE PUBLIC TO KNOW?
BUZZ ALDRIN: FIRST GUY TO
PEE IN HIS PANTS ON THE MOON.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE I HAVE
KIDS COME UP TO ME,
"HOW DO THE ASTRONAUTS
POOP AND PEE?"
[LAUGHING].
SO, BECAUSE I LOOKED INSIDE
THE COMMAND MODULE OF THE
APOLLO COMMAND MODULE;
THERE'S NO RESTROOM THAT YOU
GET UP AND GO TO.
BUZZ ALDRIN: YOU KNOW
UH ALAN, ALAN SHEPARD'S...
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION.
BUZZ ALDRIN: FLIGHT WAS
GOING TO BE A PRETTY SHORT ONE.
SO HE WAS SUPPOSED TO GO
OUT THERE, GET IN THIS MERCURY,
UH FIRST TIME, FIRST
AMERICAN, SUB ORBIT.
AND THE LAUNCH COUNTDOWN
DIDN'T QUITE GO THE WAY
IT WAS EXPECTED.
IT WAS DELAYED,
DELAYED, DELAYED.
AND ALAN'S LYING ON HIS BACK.
PRETTY SOON IT'S GETTING
PRETTY DAMP THERE.
AND THAT'S WHEN THEY FIGURE
WE, WE GOT TO UH, DO SOMETHING.
WE GOT TO HAVE A,
A LITTLE BIT
BETTER HYDRAULIC ENGINEERING.
[LAUGHING].
INTO THE SPACESUIT
AND THE RESTROOM.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
IS THAT WHAT THEY CALL IT,
HYDRAULIC ENGINEERING?
BUZZ ALDRIN: THE
"UCD," VERY IMPORTANT,
URINE COLLECTION DEVICE.
AND THE UCD...
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
OKAY, SOMEHOW I THOUGHT THOSE
WORDS WOULD BE BIGGER.
IT JUST, IT'S YOUR,
IT'S A PEE COLLECTION DEVICE.
THAT'S ALL IT IS.
BUZZ ALDRIN:
IT GETS DUMPED OVER.
IT GETS DUMPED OVERBOARD AND,
AND IT FREEZES IMMEDIATELY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
INSTANTLY, YEAH.
BUZZ ALDRIN:
AND THEY'RE FLAKES.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
BUT DOESN'T THE PIECE...
BUZZ ALDRIN:
THEY'RE FLAKES OUTSIDE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
THE PEE IS MOVING THE
SAME SPEED AS YOUR SHIP.
BUZZ ALDRIN:
OF COURSE IT WOULD.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
RIGHT, SO IF YOU PUT IT
OUTSIDE NOW THE
PEE IS, IS FROZEN PEE.
IS TRAVELING ALONG SIDE
WITH YOU TO THE MOON.
BUZZ ALDRIN:
SCOTT CARPENTER SAW A LOT
OF THOSE UH FIREFLIES.
AND HE WAS SO
FASCINATED WITH THEM,
THAT HE WASN'T QUITE
LINED UP FOR RETROFIRE.
HE, HE, HE GOT THE COSINE OF
IT, WHICH IS YOU KNOW ENOUGH.
BUT THERE WAS A LITTLE
BIT OF THE SINE OF THE
ANGLE THAT HE'S OFF.
THAT'S WHY HE LANDED THERE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
IN THE WRONG PLACE.
BUZZ ALDRIN: NOT WHERE
WAS HE SUPPOSED TO GO.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
RIGHT, BUT THE FIREFLIES.
ARE YOU TELLING ME
THAT WAS HIS PEE?
BUZZ ALDRIN: YEAH, THAT
WAS THE URINE DUMP, YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THE MYSTERIOUS FIREFLY.
BUZZ ALDRIN: WELL, BUT THERE
WAS A LITTLE HESITANCY ABOUT
PEOPLE UH GETTING THEIR
JEWEL TO CLOSE TO WHAT WAS
GOING TO,
GO TO A VACUUM.
THAT THEY MIGHT
GET SUCKED OUTSIDE.
[LAUGHTER]
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO WE HAVE TO ASK, MIKE.
UH, HAVE YOU EVER PEED
IN YOUR PANTS IN SPACE?
MIKE MASSIMINO: YES.
WE DIDN'T CALL IT THE
UCD, WE CALLED IT THE MAG.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THE MAG?
MIKE MASSIMINO: THE
MAXIMUM ABSORBENCY GARMENT.
IT WAS A DIAPER.
NEIL AND ILIZA: DIAPER.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YES.
WE WORE A DIAPER ON
UH LAUNCH AND ENTRY,
AND WHILE SPACEWALKING.
AND THEN WHEN YOU'RE
INSIDE THE SPACECRAFT,
YOU USE THE TOILET.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: OKAY,
SO WHERE DOES THE PEE GO IF
YOU DO IT IN THE SPACECRAFT?
MIKE MASSIMINO:
IN THE SPACECRAFT,
IT'S COLLECTED AND THEN
DUMPED AS, AS HE DESCRIBED.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: DUMPED.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH,
YOU WOULD WANT TO SEE THE,
THE URINE DUMP WAS COOL.
BECAUSE THEY WOULD...
YEAH, YOU WOULD DUMP IT,
AND IT WOULD CRYSTALIZE,
AND THE SUN WOULD SHINE ON IT.
AND, AND IT WAS REALLY FUN.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: BEAUTIFUL.
MIKE MASSIMINO: IT WAS
SOMETHING THE ASTRONAUTS
LOOKED FORWARD TO.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE HAVING
A CONVERSATION OF BEAUTIFUL
FROZEN PEE IN SPACE.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
YEAH, A URINE DUMP.
"HEY EVERYBODY,
IT'S A URINE DUMP."
I, I, "HEY, IT'S
A URINE DUMP."
AND THEN WE YOU KNOW,
BEFORE YOU HIT THE SWITCH,
EVERYONE GO TO THE WINDOW AND
WATCH AND SO THAT'S IT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: SO
YOU'RE TELLING ME YOUR PEE WAS
ORBITING THE EARTH.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
APPARENTLY, YES,
I NEVER THOUGHT
OF IT THAT WAY,
BUT YES FOR A LITTLE
BIT UNTIL IT CRYSTALIZE,
YOU KNOW IF IT
KIND OF DISAPPEARS.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
NO, THEN IT WOULD REENTER
THE ATMOSPHERE.
YES, YES, YES.
MIKE MASSIMINO: WELL, OKAY,
YES, I PEED ON EVERYBODY, YES.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YOU PEED, YOU PEED ON EARTH!
OH MY GOSH!
MIKE MASSIMINO:
NOW, NOW THAT YOU KNOW,
THE SECRET'S OUT, THAT'S IT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: UH,
MORE OF MY INTERVIEW WITH
AMERICAN NATIONAL EARTH
HERO, BUZZ ALDRIN,
WHEN STARTALK CONTINUES.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE].
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WELCOME BACK TO STARTALK.
WE ARE HERE AT THE AMERICAN
MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY IN
NEW YORK CITY.
AND TONIGHT'S SHOW
IS ALL ABOUT THE LEGACY OF
THE APOLLO PROGRAM.
AND WE ARE FEATURING MY
INTERVIEW WITH THE ONE,
THE ONLY APOLLO 11 PILOT,
BUZZ ALDRIN.
LET'S CHECK IT OUT.
YOU'RE SITTING ON TOP
OF THE SATURN V, OKAY?
READY TO GO TO THE MOON.
DOES YOUR MORTALITY MATTER
TO YOU AT THAT POINT THAT
YOU'RE SITTING ON THIS
32 STORY CONTROLLED EXPLOSION?
BUZZ ALDRIN: UH,
PROBABLY OVER PRETTY QUICK.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THAT WOULD BE FOR SURE.
MAY, OR, OR BECAUSE MANY OF
YOU GUYS WERE FIGHTER PILOTS
AND TEST PILOTS.
THE IDEA THAT YOU'RE PUTTING
YOUR LIFE AT RISK FOR SOME
PIECE OF MACHINERY WAS NOT
A NEW CONCERN OF YOURS.
BUZZ ALDRIN: UH EVERYTHING
THAT NASA DID HAD A
RELIABILITY TO IT.
AND IT ENDED UP, 95% YOU GUYS
ARE GOING TO COME BACK SAFELY.
WE WERE PRETTY
HAPPY WITH THAT, REALLY.
BUT WHAT WAS THE CHANCE
BEFORE WE LIFT OFF OF BEING
EVERYTHING TO GO ALRIGHT.
AND NOT HAVE TO ABORT OR
THE, AND SAFELY LANDING.
NOBODY WAS GOING TO COME
UP WITH THAT NUMBER.
BUT THE THREE OF US DID.
60% IS WHAT WE SETTLED ON.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THIS WAS YOU, NEIL ARMSTRONG.
BUZZ ALDRIN: AND WE LANDED
SIX OUT OF SEVEN OF THEM.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
MICHAEL COLLINS.
BUZZ ALDRIN: YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO IF I DON'T MEAN TO GET
MORBID ON YOU, BUT IF
YOU HAD DIED ON THE MOON...
WE'RE WE READY FOR THAT HERE
IN AMERICA, HERE ON EARTH?
BUZZ ALDRIN: EVERY PRESIDENT,
THEY HAVE A SPEECH WRITER,
A STAFF.
AND A STAFF WRITER TO THE
PRESIDENT, WOULD OF COURSE,
PREPARE IN THE EVENT SOME
DISASTER UNFOLDED LIKE
CHALLENGER ACCIDENT.
UH AND IT'S NOT
SURPRISING ME AT ALL
THAT ONE WOULD DO THAT.
BUT IT KIND OF UH,
UH IT, NOT SHOCKS,
BUT IT BRINGS PEOPLE
INTO THE REALITY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: SO I
HAVE SOME OF THOSE WORDS THAT
WERE PREPARED IN CASE
BUZZ ALDRIN AND NEIL ARMSTRONG
WOULD BE STRANDED ON THE MOON,
STILL ALIVE BUT WE WOULD KNOW
THEY WOULD ULTIMATELY DIE.
THESE WORDS WERE WRITTEN
FOR PRESIDENT NIXON,
AND HE NEVER HAD TO READ THEM,
BUT THEY EXIST AND THEY ARE IN
HIS PRESIDENTIAL ARCHIVES.
"FATE HAS ORDAINED THAT THE
MEN WHO WENT TO THE MOON TO
EXPLORE IN PEACE WILL STAY
ON THE MOON TO REST IN PEACE."
ILIZA SHLESINGER: OH MY GOD.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
"THESE BRAVE MEN,
NEIL ARMSTRONG
AND EDWIN ALDRIN,
KNOW THAT THERE IS NO
HOPE FOR THEIR RECOVERY.
BUT THEY ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE IS HOPE FOR MANKIND
IN THEIR SACRIFICE.
THESE TWO MEN ARE LAYING
DOWN THEIR LIVES IN MANKIND'S
MOST NOBLE GOAL: THE SEARCH
FOR TRUTH AND UNDERSTANDING."
THAT'S CREEPY, BUT BEAUTIFUL.
MIKE MASSIMINO: WHEN THOSE
GUYS WERE COMING BACK,
THEY HAD ANOTHER LAUNCH TO GO
THROUGH TO GET OFF THE MOON.
THAT'S WHY THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT THEM STAYING
ON THE MOON.
THAT ROCKET DID NOT WORK ON
THE MOON, THEY WERE STUCK.
AND I THINK IF, IF THEY
WERE NOT SUCCESSFUL,
I THINK WE WOULD
HAVE CONTINUED.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THAT.
EVEN WITH THE, WITH THE
UH SHUTTLE ACCIDENTS.
I REMEMBER AFTER
WE HAD CHALLENGER,
I BECAME AN ASTRONAUT
AFTER THAT AND BEFORE
THE SECOND MISSION.
WE SAID OH, IF YOU HAVE
AN ACCIDENT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S GOING TO END THE PROGRAM.
AND, AND IT, IT DIDN'T.
YOU KNOW, WE HAD ANOTHER
ACCIDENT, AND WE KEPT GOING.
THAT'S, THAT'S A PART OF IT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND, AND, AND, IN YOUR...
ILIZA SHLESINGER: IT'S
AMERICAN SPIRIT, TOO.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND, AND, AND IN YOUR
PARTICULAR CASE,
YOU, YOU WERE ON A
DANGEROUS SHUTTLE MISSION.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A BACKUP
MISSION TO SAVE YOU...
MIKE MASSIMINO:
NO, THAT'S RIGHT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND YOU DID THIS KNOWING
YOU WERE AT RISK OF DEATH.
AND YOU DID THIS
FOR WE THE ASTROPHYSICISTS
TO FIX OUR TELESCOPE.
SO UH, I HAVE TO ASSUME THE
ANSWER TO THIS NEXT QUESTION
IS YES, BUT I NEED YOU
ON RECORD TO SAY SO,
WAS IT WORTH THE RISK?
MIKE MASSIMINO: YES,
ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: YES IT WAS.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WE GOT IT.
WELL THANK YOU BECAUSE I,
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE,
EVEN AMONG MY, IN MY
ASTROPHYSICS COMMUNITY,
WHO WOULD HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF
THE RIGHT STUFF TO EVEN HAVE
FIXED OUR OWN DAMN TELESCOPE.
SO THANK YOU.
AND, CAUSE YOU'RE
NOT AN ASTRO, YOU.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
YOU'RE, YOU'RE WELCOME,
IT GAVE ME SOMETHING TO DO.
NO, IT'S A, THE TELESCOPE I
THINK IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
HOW ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS
KIND OF WORK TOGETHER.
ENGINEER, I ENJOYED FIXING IT,
YOU GUYS LOOK THROUGH IT.
AND IT'S A VERY
NICE RELATIONSHIP.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO, NOW YOU'RE UP IN ORBIT,
LOW EARTH ORBIT,
350 MILES UP.
BUT BUZZ IS ONE OF
TWELVE PEOPLE TO HAVE BEEN
TO THE MOON.
AND, AND I HAD TO ASK HIM
ABOUT THAT UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE.
THE PERS, PERSPECTIVE OF
SETTING YOUR FOOT ON SOMETHING
OTHER THAN EARTH,
LET'S CHECK IT OUT.
WE ALWAYS HERE
ABOUT ASTRONAUTS,
HUMAN BEINGS WHO HAVE
GONE INTO SPACE AND THEY'VE
COME BACK IN SOME OTHER
MENTAL PERSPECTIVE.
ARE YOU IN ANOTHER
STATE OF MIND?
BUZZ ALDRIN: IT'S, ITS'
CALLED THE OVERVIEW.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THE OVERVIEW.
YOU CAN HAVE AN OVERVIEW
EFFECT JUST BEING IN ORBIT?
BUZZ ALDRIN: YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND THEN FOR THE NINE MISSIONS
THAT LEFT EARTH ORBIT
TO GO TO THE MOON.
YOU NOW SEE EARTH
RECEDING IN THE DISTANCE.
THAT'S GOTTA AFFECT
YOU IN SOME WAY.
THAT'S HOME GETTING SMALLER.
BUZZ ALDRIN: YOU KNOW WE'D BE
IN TROUBLE IF IT GOT BIGGER.
THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN LATER ON.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
LATER ON.
YOU WANT THAT ON THE, ON
THE BACKSIDE OF THIS, OKAY.
OH, OKAY, ALRIGHT.
BUZZ ALDRIN: YEAH YOU GOT
TO, YOU GOT TO PUT THE...
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
OKAY, ALRIGHT, SO YOU EXPECT
IT TO GET SMALLER.
IT'S GETTING SMALLER.
ALL IS FINE.
OKAY, I HADN'T THOUGHT
ABOUT IT THAT WAY.
OKAY, SO I...
HE'S NOT KNOWN FOR BEING
SENTIMENTAL, YOU KNOW.
HE'S, HE'S JUST
VERY MATTER OF FACT.
AND IN, IN FACT, THERE'S
A FAMOUS PHOTO OF HIM
SALUTING THE
FLAG ON THE MOON.
HE'S QUOTED, IN
HIS BOOK AS SAYING,
WHEN HE SALUTED THE
FLAG ON THE MOON, THAT,
HE'S NOT GIVEN
TO EMOTIONALISM.
BUT IN THAT MOMENT,
PATRIOTISM AND LOVE
OF COUNTRY OVERWHELMED HIM.
MIKE MASSIMINO: WOW.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND THIS IS AT A TIME WHERE,
WHERE AT WAR
WITH THE, YOU KNOW,
AT COLD WAR WITH THE RUSSIANS,
AND THERE'S
AMERICAN FLAG IS THERE.
AND SO, SO DID YOU
FEEL NATIONALISTIC?
LIKE I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
PATRIOTIC LIKE THAT?
MIKE MASSIMINO: I UH,
YES, CERTAINLY I DID.
I WAS VERY PROUD TO
HAVE AN AMERICAN FLAG
ON MY LEFT SHOULDER.
AND UH, WHEN I WAS SPACE
WALKING AND IT'S A LOT OF
NATIONAL PRIDE, WE LIVE
IN A GREAT COUNTRY.
AND I THINK ALL ASTRONAUTS
GO AS REPRESENTATIVES OF,
OF LOTS OF THINGS.
YOU KNOW THE NEIGHBORHOODS
THEY CAME FROM,
THE SCHOOLS THEY WENT TO,
AND CERTAINLY THE COUNTRIES
THEY'RE FROM, SO YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WAS THERE EVER A MOMENT WHERE
YOU HAD TO SORT OF
OVERRIDE WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A NATURAL EMOTION?
TO TAKE CARE OF
SOME OTHER TASK?
MIKE MASSIMINO:
YEAH, YOU KNOW,
YOU KIND OF HAVE TO
KEEP THINGS IN CHECK.
AND A LOT OF, YOU KNOW,
FOR ME A LOT OF IT WAS,
THE, THE EMOTIONAL PART OF
IT REALLY DIDN'T COME OUT
UNTIL I GOT BACK.
AND YOU START THINKING
ABOUT WHAT YOU DID,
AND THEN THE EMOTIONS
ALLOWED TO ESCAPE.
SO I GOT VERY EMOTIONAL
REALLY LIKE THE,
THE DAY AFTER I GOT BACK
IS THINKING ABOUT STUFF,
YOU CAN'T, YOU CAN'T
HOLD IT IN SOME WAYS.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
BECAUSE YOU'RE COMPLETELY HUMAN.
THIS IS ENCOURAGING.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
YEAH, UH, YOU KNOW.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: IT
PROBABLY TAKES YOU A WHILE
TO PROCESS THAT.
JUST, I MEAN IT'S
SUCH AN INCREDIBLE.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH, IT IS.
YOU KNOW, I REMEMBER
LIKE GETTING BACK.
AND JUST, YOU KNOW, AND
YOU START THINKING ABOUT
WHAT YOU DID, AND IT, IT
REALLY, YOU'RE ALLOWED THEN
TO RELEASE AT THAT POINT.
AND UH THAT'S THE
WAY IT AFFECTED ME.
BUT YEAH, YOU HAVE TO,
YOU TRY TO KEEP IT IN CHECK.
I THINK THE, YOU KNOW,
THE, THE JOYFUL EMOTION,
THAT'S A, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
UH, BUT THE OTH, THE OTHER
SIDE OF IT, NOT PANICKING.
YOU KNOW, WHEN THINGS
ARE GOING WRONG.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE YOU'RE JUST GOING TO
MAKE IT WORSE, SO.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
COOL, WELL, UP NEXT,
AFTER THE COMMERCIAL BREAK,
OUR MAN ABOUT TOWN CHUCK NICE
GOES INTO THE PUBLIC AND
EXPLORES WHAT PEOPLE
KNOW OR DO NOT KNOW ABOUT
THE MOON LANDING.
WHEN STARTALK RETURNS.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE].
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WE'RE BACK ON STARTALK.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUZZ ALDRIN'S HISTORIC TRIP
TO THE MOON.
AND BEFORE WE GET BACK
TO MY CLIPS OF HIM,
LET'S GO TO OUR MAN IN
THE STREET, CHUCK NICE.
TO SEE WHAT THE PUBLIC THINKS
ABOUT THE MOON VOYAGES,
CHECK IT OUT.
CHUCK NICE:
THAT'S RIGHT, NEIL!
WE'RE HERE ON THE STREETS OF
NEW YORK CITY TO FIND OUT WHAT
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT THE
LEGACY OF THE MOON LANDING.
DID WE EVEN REALLY GO?
LET'S FIND OUT.
DO YOU BELIEVE WE
LANDED ON THE MOON,
OR DO YOU THINK IT WAS A HOAX?
MAN: I BELIEVE WE
LANDED ON THE MOON.
CHUCK NICE: WHY?
MAN: UH, THERE'S PICTURES.
WE LANDED, I MEAN,
I WASN'T THERE, BUT UH...
CHUCK NICE: RIGHT, BUT
YOU KNOW THAT WE LANDED.
MAN: I, YEAH,
I, I THINK SO.
CHUCK NICE: DO YOU
BELIEVE IN BIGFOOT?
MAN: UH, NO.
CHUCK NICE: THANK GOD.
MAN: NO.
WOMAN: I DON'T THINK
THAT WAS A HOAX,
THAT DEFINITELY HAPPENED.
I DON'T SEE HOW
IT COULDN'T HAVE.
MAN: WHAT IF THE EARTH IS A
HOAX, BUT THE MOON IS REAL?
CHUCK NICE: NOW SEE THAT,
I LIKE THE WAY YOU THINK.
DID YOU EVER WANT TO BE AN
ASTRONAUT WHEN YOU WERE A KID?
MAN: SURE, DIDN'T
EVERYBODY BACK IN MY AGE?
I MEAN, I'M, I
WAS BORN IN 1954.
I GREW UP IN THE SIXTIES, WHEN
ALL THAT STUFF WAS HAPPENING.
AND AT LEAST AT SOME POINT,
EVERY KID WANTED TO BE AN
ASTRONAUT AT THAT TIME.
CHUCK NICE: AND WHAT
DID YOU END UP BEING?
MAN: A BANKER.
CHUCK NICE: SO MUCH BETTER.
MOON PEOPLE!
WHERE ARE MY MOON PEOPLE?
SO BUZZ ALDRIN ESTIMATED
THAT THERE WAS A 60% CHANCE
THAT HE WOULD GET TO THE
MOON AND BACK SAFELY.
WOULD YOU TAKE THOSE ODDS?
WOMAN: HELL NO!
MAN: UH, GOD NO.
CHUCK NICE: NO!
MAN: I WANT TO SAY YES,
BUT WHEN YOU'RE ASKING ME,
AND THINKING ABOUT
MY OWN PERSONALITY.
CHUCK NICE: RIGHT.
MAN: AND I WAS A BANKER?
NO.
CHUCK NICE: MAN HAS
SET FOOT UPON THE MOON,
WHERE SHOULD WE GO NEXT?
MAN: EVERYBODY
WANTS TO GO TO MARS.
WOMAN: LIKE, LIKE
VULCAN LAND OR?
CHUCK NICE: VULCAN,
THE PLANET VULCAN?
MAN: MARS IS A
GOOD DESTINATION.
I HAVE TO SAY THOUGH, IF WE
HAD DEVELOPED THE SENSING
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE
NOW LIKE IN MY CELL PHONE,
AND ALL OF THE ADVANCED
WAYS TO SEE AND PERCEIVE AND,
AND LEARN, BEFORE WE HAD
DEVELOPED ALL THE ROCKETS BACK
IN THE EARLY SIXTIES, HE MIGHT
NEVER HAVE GONE TO THE MOON.
CHUCK NICE: REALLY?
MAN: BECAUSE BACK IN THE DAY,
IF YOU WANTED TO LEARN WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IN
OUTER SPACE...
CHUCK NICE: YOU
COULDN'T SEND A ROBOT.
MAN: COULDN'T, COULDN'T,
HAD TO SEND A HUMAN BEING.
CHUCK NICE: HAD TO
SEND A HUMAN BEING.
NOW WE CAN SEND ROBOTS.
MAN: OR TINY STUFF.
TINY STUFF, YOU GOT IT.
CHUCK NICE: SO,
RIGHT, SO ACTUALLY,
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENT MAY
HAVE PRECLUDED BUZZ ALDRIN
FROM EVER REACHING THE MOON.
MAN: YOU'RE THE
MAN, YOU UNDERSTAND!
CHUCK NICE: BANG, I'M, I'M.
MAN: SCIENCE!
CHUCK NICE: RIGHT, SCIENCE!
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO, SO, UH,
SO I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
THIS SET OF RANDOM NEW YORKERS
IN WASHINGTON SQUARE PARK,
NONE OF THEM WERE IN DENIAL OF
THE MOON LANDING.
MIKE MASSIMINO: GOOD THING.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AS SO MANY PEOPLE ARE.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: YEAH,
SO I'M, I'M HAPPY ABOUT THAT,
HAPPY TO REPORT, MY
FELLOW NEW YORKERS.
WE GOT IT.
MIKE MASSIMINO: EDUCATED CITY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO THE UM, THE, THE, THE,
THE, THE LUNAR MODULE, AS
IT LANDED HAD A NAME, EAGLE.
THE EAGLE HAS LANDED.
THIS DETACHES FROM
THE COMMAND MODULE.
THAT'S THE ONE, THIS IS THE
THING WITH THE SPIDER LEGS,
WHICH WILL TAKE THEM DOWN
TO THE LUNAR SURFACE,
AND BRING THEM BACK.
AND LANDING ON THE MOON,
THE MOON HAS NO AIR.
SO YOU CAN'T USE
AIR RESISTANCE TO
BUOY YOUR LANDING.
THEY NEED FUEL TO SLOW DOWN
SO THEY DON'T CRASH AND
YOU NEED FUEL TO
LIFT OFF AND RETURN.
ALL OF THIS HAS TO HAPPEN.
AND SO, SO THESE DIFFERENT
COMMAND MODULES, UH,
EACH ONE HAD A DIFFERENT
COMMAND MODULE,
AND IT WASN'T OBVIOUS WHICH
ONE WOULD BE THE FIRST.
WHAT, WHAT, WHAT CRITERIA
WAS BEING USED DEPENDING
ON THE NEEDS OF THE MISSION.
AND SO I ASKED BUZZ ALDRIN A,
ABOUT HOW HIS LANDER BECAME
THE ONE CHOSEN FOR
APOLLO 11, LET'S CHECK IT OUT.
BUZZ ALDRIN: THE LUNAR
MODULES ARE COMING OFF
THE PRODUCTION LINE.
AND UH THEY'RE NOT
ASSIGNING CREWS YET BECAUSE
WE HAVEN'T QUITE GOT THERE.
BUT THE CREW SHAKE UP
BECAUSE DIFFERENT THINGS.
UH, A LANDER WASN'T READY.
AND UH, RUSSIANS WERE GOING
TO MAYBE FLY AROUND THE
MOON WITH A GUY,
INSTEAD OF JUST EMPTY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
UNMANNED?
BUZZ ALDRIN: WE FIGURED
THEY WERE GOING TO PUT
A COSMONAUT IN HER.
SO WE ACCELERATED UH APOLLO 8.
ANYWAY, THE LANDERS COMING
OFF THE PRODUCTION LINE,
UH WERE HEAVY AT FIRST.
AND THE FIRST ONE WAS
GOING TO BE LIGHT ENOUGH WAS
GOING TO BE LEM-6.
AND IT WORKED OUT TO BE
APOLLO 12 IN MID-OCTOBER.
ALRIGHT NOW THE
MANAGER OF LEM-5.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THAT'S YOUR "LEM,"
LUNAR EXCURSION MODULE.
BUZZ ALDRIN: YEAH,
HE WANTED HIS TO LAND.
AND HE WENT TO GEORGE LOW,
THE APOLLO PROGRAM HEAD.
AND HE SAID, "GEORGE IF UH,
IF I GET THE WEIGHT DOWN WILL
YOU GUARANTEE THAT MY LANDER
WILL UH BE A LANDING MISSION?"
GEORGE LOW, HEAD OF
APOLLO PROGRAM SAYS,
"WELL OF COURSE I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE ANOTHER CHANCE.
AN EARLIER CHANCE TO LAND."
SO HE WENT AHEAD AND LEM-5
BECAME QUALIFIED AND WE LANDED.
INSTEAD OF PETE CONRAD
BEING THE FIRST ON THE MOON.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
I DID NOT KNOW THIS,
UNTIL HE TOLD ME THAT.
I DID NOT KNOW THAT
APOLLO 12 WAS SCHEDULED TO
BE THE FIRST MOON LANDING.
WITH PETE CONRAD, THE
FIRST TO STEP OFF THE LEM.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE LEM LIGHT ENOUGH TO,
TO BE SERVED BY THE LIMIT,
LIMIT OF THE FUEL AVAILABLE TO
SEND IT BACK AND
COMPLETE THE MISSION.
MIKE MASSIMINO: RIGHT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO THEY, THAT SOMEONE
WORKED ON THEIR LEM.
AND SLIPPED THEM IN AHEAD.
THAT, I MEAN THAT'S,
THAT'S, THAT'S.
MIKE MASSIMINO: AMAZING.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT, EITHER.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
IT'S GANGSTER, THAT...
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
WHAT I GOT TO DO TO MAKE
MY LEM LAND FIRST.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YEAH, YEAH, THAT'S SO GANGSTER.
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
SLIP THEM A 20, YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THAT'S RIGHT, AND OF COURSE
WHAT'S HURRYING THIS
ALONG IS THAT WE HAVE A
SPACE RACE WITH
THE SOVIET UNION.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
PEOPLE REMEMBER ABOUT THAT.
MAY, MAYBE SOME OLD TIMERS DO,
BUT OTHERS MAYBE YOU
LEARNED ABOUT IT IN A BOOK.
BUT WE WERE IN COLD WAR
WITH THE SOVIET UNION.
THERE IT WAS.
OKAY?
AND IN THAT COLD WAR,
WE'RE BUILDING
UP OUR WEAPONS ARSENAL.
AND ONE KIND OF WEAPON,
WHICH WAS PARTICULARLY POTENT,
IS THE INTERCONTINENTAL
BALLISTIC MISSILE.
SO THIS IS A
MISSILE YOU LAUNCH,
AND IT LEAVES THE
ATMOSPHERE OF THE EARTH.
AND IT TRAVELS MOST OF
ITS DISTANCE SUB-ORBITAL,
THEN COMES OUT OF THE
ATMOSPHERE AND LANDS,
AND YOU WOULD LOAD THEM
WITH NUCLEAR WARHEADS,
AND IT CAN GO BETWEEN ANY
TWO POINTS ON EARTH WITHIN
FORTY-FIVE MINUTES.
YOU COULD NOT EVACUATE
A CITY IN TIME.
BECAUSE SUBORBITAL GETS
YOU HALFWAY AROUND THE EARTH
IN 45 MINUTES.
AND SO, SO
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS.
JUST IN CASE YOU DON'T KNOW.
OCTOBER 4TH 1957,
RUSSIA LAUNCHES SPUTNIK.
AND YOU READ NORMAL
ACCOUNTS OF IT,
"OH IT'S THE FIRST
SPACE SATELLITE.
OKAY, THAT'S COOL."
IT STARTS THE SPACE RACE.
WHY DID WE FREAK OUT?
BECAUSE THAT WAS IN A
HOLLOWED OUT SHELL OF AN
INTERCONTINENTAL
BALLISTIC MISSILE!
AND IF THEY COULD FLY A
SATELLITE THAT WENT BEEP-BEEP
OVER OUR HEAD, THAT WAS
A, THAT WAS THE WRITING
ON THE WALL.
THAT WAS, THEY CAN SEND
ANYTHING OVER OUR HEAD.
AND WE WENT BALLISTIC.
AND WE, HA,HA, SO, SO
A, A YEAR AND A DAY LATER,
I'M BORN.
BUT THAT'S BESIDE THE POINT.
UH, A YEAR LATER THAT
WEEK, THE WEEK I WAS BORN,
NASA IS FOUNDED.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: WOW.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND THAT BIRTHS OUR SPACE,
OUR PARTICIPATION
IN THE SPACE RACE.
SO, SO THEN WE ACTUALLY
LAUNCHED THE RACE TO THE MOON
WITH JFK'S SPEECH.
BECAUSE RUSSIA BEAT US
IN ALMOST EVERYTHING ELSE,
AND HE THINKS MAYBE WE
CAN BEAT THEM IN GETTING
TO THE MOON.
SO WE LAUNCHED THAT.
SO THE, THAT'S THE, THAT'S
THE STORY IN A NUTSHELL.
AND WE HAVE THE MERCURY
PROGRAM, THE GEMINI PROGRAM.
MERCURY HOLDS ONE
ASTRONAUT, GEMINI HOLDS TWO,
GEMINI TWINS, OF COURSE.
UH, APOLLO HOLDS THREE.
AND THERE YOU HAVE IT.
BUT DURING THAT APOLLO ERA,
WE WERE SPENDING MORE THAN
4% OF THE FEDERAL
BUDGET GOING INTO SPACE,
NOW IT'S ONE HALF OF
1% OF THE FEDERAL BUDGET.
SO THE VALUATION IS WAY LOWER.
BUT WE DID MANAGE
TO DO OTHER THINGS.
WE HAD SKYLAB, WE
HAD THE APOLLO SOYUZ.
UH, THE SOYUZ IS
THE RUSSIAN CAPSULE.
THEY, THEY CONNECTED,
REMEMBER THAT?
MIKE MASSIMINO:
YEAH. I REMEMBER THAT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: AND
OF COURSE, THE SPACE STATION.
DID YOU EVER GET TO
THE SPACE STATION?
MIKE MASSIMINO: I'VE NEVER
BEEN TO THE SPACE STATION.
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
OH, YOU HAVE TO GO.
MIKE MASSIMINO: REALLY?
ILIZA SHLESINGER: MUST GO.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
WHY, WHAT'S IT LIKE?
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
GO IN THE SPRING.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
HOW'S THE FOOD?
ILIZA SHLESINGER: IT'S
AMAZING, EVERYTHING'S FRESH.
MIKE MASSIMINO: GOOD SERVICE?
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: SO.
COMING UP AFTER THE BREAK,
MORE OF MY INTERVIEW WITH
MOONWALKER,
NATIONAL TREASURE,
BUZZ ALDRIN WHEN
STARTALK CONTINUES.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE].
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WE'RE BACK ON STARTALK.
HERE AT THE ROSE CENTER
FOR EARTH AND SPACE.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE HISTORIC MISSION TO PUT
A MAN ON THE MOON.
AND BACK THEN IN
THE AGE OF APOLLO,
GREAT RISKS WERE TAKEN
FOR GREAT REWARDS.
AND I WONDERED TODAY,
IS THAT SAME RISK REWARD
RATIO STILL IN EFFECT?
AND I ASKED APOLLO 11 PILOT,
BUZZ ALDRIN ALL ABOUT IT,
LET'S CHECK IT OUT.
WE'RE IN A CULTURE NOW
WHERE EVERYONE IS AFRAID
TO MAKE A MISTAKE.
BECAUSE SOMETHING GOES
WRONG AND THEN SOMEBODY
HAS TO HAND OUT BLAME.
AND I WORRY THAT WE LIVE
IN A TIME VERY DIFFERENT
FROM WHEN I GREW UP, WHEN
WE'RE SENDING YOU TO THE MOON.
WHERE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DISCOVER ANYTHING,
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE GUN SHY,
EXPLORATION SHY, RISK DIVERSE.
BUZZ ALDRIN:
YEAH, UH, THERE'S,
THERE'S AN ENGINEER WHO'S
MADE KIND OF A SPECIALTY OF
UH OF REALLY ANALYZING HOW
MUCH IT COST US TO BE SO
SURE THAT
SOMETHING WON'T FAIL.
WE SPEND SO MUCH
MONEY TO DO THAT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WE SPEND MONEY TO NOT FAIL.
BUZZ ALDRIN: A LOT, OH YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: NOT,
NOT REALIZING THE VALUE OF
FAILURE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SO MAYBE NASA NEEDS
A SKUNK WORKS.
THEY NEED A, A...
BUZZ ALDRIN: WELL WE GOT
ONE, WE GOT ONE DOWN,
DOWN IN FLORIDA.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: WHERE?
BUZZ ALDRIN: YOU KNOW,
THEY GOT ALLIGATORS AND STUFF.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: WHAT?
BUZZ ALDRIN: BUT, BUT
THIS IS KENNEDY SPACE CENTER
AND THEY HAVE A SWAMP WORKS.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: SO
IF YOUR, IF YOUR LAUNCH FAILS...
YOU GET EATEN BY
ALLIGATOR, OKAY.
BUZZ ALDRIN:
THERE'S SWAMP WORKS, OKAY?
DOWN WHERE THE ALLIGATORS
ARE, THERE'S SWAMPS.
AND THEY ARE UH
GETTING INTO SOME...
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO THIS IS REAL?
BUZZ ALDRIN: ABSOLUTELY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT THE SWAMP WORKS.
ONE OF THE, ONE OF BUZZ'S
FAVORITE QUOTES IS A VARIANT
ON THE ONE WE ALL LEARNED
FROM THE APOLLO 13 MOVIE.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
"FAILURE IS NOT AN OPTION."
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
AND BUZZ HAS A
DIFFERENT TAKE ON THAT.
IN HIS BOOK HE SAYS, "NO,
FAILURE IS ALWAYS AN OPTION."
UH, ONE OF THE LESSONS HE
DESCRIBES IN THAT BOOK.
BECAUSE IF FAILURE
IS NOT AN OPTION,
THEN YOU'RE AT RISK
OF BEING TOO SAFE.
AND IN FACT,
LOCKHEED MARTIN AND,
THE PENTAGON AND OTHERS
HAVE GOTTEN TOGETHER.
SO THEY HAD WHAT WAS
CALLED THE SKUNK WORKS.
WHERE THEY UH WOULD DESIGN
ADVANCED UH AVIATION ELEMENTS.
AND OUT OF THAT CAME
THINGS LIKE STEALTH AND UH
VERY HIGH SPEED CRAFT.
YOU KNOW, HIGH MACH NUMBER.
UH, MULTIPLE TIMES THE
SPEED OF SOUND AND,
AND IN THAT GROUP, THEY
HAD VERY LITTLE OVERSIGHT.
VERY LITTLE MANAGEMENT
TELLING THEM WHAT
BOTTOM LINE TO, TO MATCH.
AND ONLY THEN DID I JUST
LEARN THAT NASA HAS THAT.
I'M, I'M ASHAMED,
I DIDN'T KNOW THIS.
THE, THE SWAMP WORKS.
DID YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE SWAMP WORKS?
MIKE MASSIMINO: YOU KNOW I,
I HAD A STUDENT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO THAT HAD
A SUMMER INTERNSHIP THERE.
SO I, I LEARNED
ABOUT IT THROUGH HIM.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
UH-HUH, DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT
STUFF THEY WERE DOING?
MIKE MASSIMINO:
THEY WERE DOING SOME REALLY
COOL ROBOTIC STUFF.
SOME LIKE CUTTING EDGE,
COOL ROBOTIC STUFF THAT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WITHOUT SOME MANAGER COMING
OVER SAY, "YOU GOT
TO MAKE THE BOTTOM LINE."
MIKE MASSIMINO: UH,
I, I THINK THAT'S WHAT,
THAT WAS THE IDEA,
DO SOME EXCITING STUFF, YEAH.
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
IT'S A THINK TANK.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YEAH, A THINK TANK.
BUT THEY'RE, THEY'RE,
THEY'RE DOING MORE THAN
JUST THINKING, YES.
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
IT'S A BUILD TANK.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THEY'RE DOING, YEAH,
THANK YOU...
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
IT'S AN EXPLOSION TANK.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
IT'S, IT'S, IT'S A DO TANK,
IT, IT, IT'S A DO TANK.
AND, AND GETTING BACK
TO THE BUZZ AND THE RISK.
HERE'S SOMETHING INTERESTING.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE RISKING YOUR LIFE FOR,
WHY RISK IT AT ALL?
MIKE MASSIMINO:
IT'S A GOOD POINT.
YEAH IF YOU JUST NOT,
YOU DON'T HAVE A DEFINED GOAL.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WE'LL JUST GO IN SPACE,
I DON'T KNOW WHERE.
I DON'T KNOW, AND THEN
YOU PUT YOUR LIFE AT RISK,
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT?
MIKE MASSIMINO:
WELL, YEAH, IT'S NOT,
IT'S NOT A REALLY A
GREAT IDEA, ACTUALLY.
YOU KNOW AND, AND PART OF
THE REASON AS ASTRONAUTS WERE
WILLING TO TAKE THAT RISK,
YOU TALKED ABOUT HUBBLE'S.
BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT
SOMETHING GREAT COULD COME
OUT OF IT, SO.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO YOU WERE ABLE TO CALCULATE
THE RETURN ON THAT RISK.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, AND PLUS
YOU KNEW WE WERE WATCHING.
IF YOU CAME BACK HERE
AND YOU HAD FAILED,
I WOULD HAVE
KICKED, KICKED YOU.
MIKE MASSIMINO: WELL
THAT'S THE OTHER THING.
YOU WOULDN'T BE SO...
YEAH, YOU WOULDN'T HAVE
ME ON YOUR SHOW IF I
SCREWED UP YOUR TELESCOPE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
EXACTLY, IF YOU BUSTED
THE MIRROR.
MIKE MASSIMINO: FAILURE WASN'T
AN OPTION IN THAT CASE SO YES
NEIL WOULD HAVE BEEN PISSED.
SO YEAH, THESE, YOU KNOW
THESE ASTRONOMERS WOULD HAVE
BEEN REALLY ANGRY, SO WE
COULDN'T FAIL ON THAT ONE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WELL, SO NO, JUST TALK
ABOUT NOT RISKING;
NO HUMANS HAVE BEEN OUT OF
LOW EARTH ORBIT...
MIKE MASSIMINO:
FOR A LONG TIME.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
MUCH LESS HAVE BEEN TO
THE MOON SINCE 1972.
THERE'S NO NEW
FOOTPRINTS ANYWHERE.
OUTSIDE OF LOW EARTH ORBIT.
AND WE GOT, I THINK
WE GOT A FOOTPRINT,
WHAT DO WE HAVE ON
THE SCREEN HERE?
THERE IT IS.
SO IT TURNS OUT THAT
FOOTPRINT IS, YOU KNOW,
"ONE SMALL STEP FOR MAN",
THAT'S BUZZ ALDRIN'S FOOTPRINT,
THAT'S NOT
NEIL ARMSTRONG'S FOOTPRINT.
MIKE MASSIMINO: MMM.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THAT'S BUZZ.
NOW I DON'T KNOW
HOW THEY ALL KNOW THAT.
BECAUSE I BET THEIR
BOOTS WERE PRETTY SIMILAR.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: NO WAY.
BUZZ WOULD BE LIKE,
"MINE WERE BIGGER."
ANY GUY WOULD, RIGHT?
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO UP NEXT ON STARTALK,
WE'LL TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE APOLLO MOON LANDING
IN THE SEGMENT WE CALL,
COSMIC QUERIES, WHEN WE RETURN.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE].
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WELCOME BACK TO STARTALK.
WE DEVOTED THIS WHOLE PROGRAM
TO THE APOLLO LEGACY IN MY
INTERVIEW WITH APOLLO
GREAT, BUZZ ALDRIN.
AND RIGHT NOW, IT'S
TIME FOR COSMIC QUERIES.
IN THIS, IN THIS SEGMENT,
WE HAVE SOLICITED QUESTIONS
FROM OUR FAN BASE.
ALL THROUGHOUT SOCIAL MEDIA.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THEM BEFORE.
IF I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER,
I'LL JUST SAY I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER, GIVE ME ANOTHER ONE.
BUT I GOT YOU TO
HELP ME, MIKE.
SO GIVE IT TO US,
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: FROM MATT
ELI IN SAN ANTONIO, TEXAS.
"WHY DO SO MANY PEOPLE
REFUSE TO BELIEVE IN
THE MOON LANDING?"
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: MIKE?
MIKE MASSIMINO: UH, I THINK
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH AN AMAZING
FEAT, WE CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT WE ACTUALLY DID IT.
AND THAT'S THE ONLY THING
I CAN THINK, BUT WE DID IT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
I, I ACTUALLY AGREE.
I THINK WHAT A TESTAMENT
TO HOW FAR OUR SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERING HAS COME, THAT,
PEOPLE WITHIN OUR OWN CULTURE
ARE IN DENIAL OF WHAT THOSE
ACHIEVEMENTS ACTUALLY ARE.
THAT IS AN EVEN GREATER
TESTAMENT TO WHAT THE
ACHIEVEMENTS HAVE BEEN.
SO I'M TOTALLY
WITH YOU ON THAT.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: THOSE
ARE BOTH INCORRECT,
NO POINTS REWARDED.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
I FORGOT SHE'S A GAMESHOW HOST.
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
NEXT QUESTION IS FOR
A CASIO KEYBOARD.
ARE YOU READY?
OKAY, UH, FROM SIRMATTHEW42.
"CAN YOU ONCE AND FOR ALL
EXPLAIN TO THE MOON LANDING
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS WHY
THE RADIATION BELT DIDN'T KILL
THE APOLLO ASTRONAUTS?"
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: OOH,
SO DID YOU GO THROUGH THE
RADIATION BELT?
MIKE MASSIMINO: WE WERE,
WHERE'S THE VAN ALLEN BELT?
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WAIT, WAIT, HAVE YOU HAD
KIDS SINCE YOU?
MIKE MASSIMINO:
NO, I WONDER WHY?
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
BECAUSE YOU WERE WITH IT.
MIKE MASSIMINO: UM.
WELL THE, THE RADIATION
BELT, AND NEIL'S PROBABLY CAN
EXPLAIN THIS
BETTER THAN I CAN,
BUT THE RADIATION BELT ALSO
PROTECTS US FROM RADIATION.
IT'S WHEN YOU GET OUTSIDE
OF THE VAN ALLEN BELTS WHERE
YOU'RE MORE EXPOSED.
SO THEY WERE EXPOSED ONCE
THEY GOT AWAY FROM THE
EARTH'S PROTECTION
OF OUR MAGNETIC FIELD,
BUT THEY LUCKILY
DID NOT GET ZAPPED WITH
ANYTHING TOO HARMFUL.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: WELL,
YEAH, SO, SO IF I ADD SOME,
SOME NUANCE TO THAT.
SO, SO WE HAVE A
MAGNETIC FIELD,
AND CHARGE PARTICLES
COME FROM THE SUN,
WHICH WOULD OTHERWISE
BE DANGEROUS TO YOU.
AND THEY GET DIRECTED
TO THE POLES,
COLLIDE WITH OUR ATMOSPHERE,
RENDER IT AGLOW INTO THE
AURORA BOREALIS.
IN THE AURORA AUSTRALIS,
THE NORTHERN LIGHTS.
SO CREDIT THE SUN
FOR THAT ACTIVITY.
NOW IF YOU GO INTO ORBIT,
GO TO THE MOON, AND COME BACK.
IF YOU ARE ON THE MOON
AND THERE'S A SOLAR FLARE,
A MEGA SOLAR FLARE,
THAT'S BAD FOR YOU, RIGHT?
SO FUTURE MISSIONS
TO THE MOON,
YOU WANT TO TIME IT FOR WHEN
THE SUN IS NOT FLARE ACTIVE.
AND THE SUN GOES
THROUGH CYCLES.
SO YOU KNOW WHEN IT'S AT
A LOW PERIOD, YOU'RE SAFER.
THE ASTRONAUTS THAT
WENT UP BACK THEN,
THEY WERE EXPOSED
TO RADIATION,
BUT IT WAS NOT VERY MUCH.
AND NOT ALL LEVELS OF ALL
RADIATION ARE BAD FOR YOU.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: NOT ALL
RADIATION IS BAD FOR YOU.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: YES.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: THAT
IS THE CORRECT ANSWER.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
OKAY, WHAT ELSE YOU GOT?
OKAY, WHAT DO WE WIN?
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH,
WHAT ARE WE GETTING NOW?
ILIZA SHLESINGER: THE KEYBOARD,
YOU SAID THE KEYBOARD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
OH, THE KEYBOARD, CASIO
KEYBOARD, ALRIGHT.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: FROM
NICOLE BROOKS IN PHILADELPHIA.
"HOW WOULD A SOVIET MANNED
MOON LANDING HAVE AFFECTED THE
COURSE OF THE COLD WAR?"
NEIL AND MIKE: OOOH.
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
OOH, HYPOTHETICALS.
MIKE MASSIMINO: THEY
WOULD HAVE, THEY,
THEY WOULD HAVE WON, AND
UH, IT WOULD HAVE UH, UH I,
I, I THINK IT WOULD HAVE
GIVEN THEM AN EDGE.
AND MAYBE THE SOVIET UNION
MIGHT EVEN STILL
BE AROUND TODAY.
ILIZA SHLESINGER:
YEAH, IT WOULD.
WE MIGHT BE CALLING
IT PHILADELPHIA NOW.
LIKE, WITH AN ACCENT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
OOH, YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK?
I THINK HAD THEY DONE THAT,
WE WOULD HAVE SAID,
"UH NO, THE REAL RACE IS
WHO LANDS ON MARS FIRST."
YEAH, WE WOULD HAVE KEPT.
MIKE MASSIMINO: DANG IT!
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YEAH, YEAH, SEE?
SEE, THAT'S WHAT
I THINK WE WOULD HAVE DONE.
MIKE MASSIMINO: OH, WOW.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
ALRIGHT, NEXT ONE, GO!
ILIZA SHLESINGER: LAST ONE.
FROM BEAUTIFUL DUST SPECKS,
"IF THE FUNDING AND BACKING
FOR SPACE TRAVEL TODAY
WAS EQUAL RELATIVE,"
SHE MEANT TO SAY
EQUALLY RELATIVE,
"TO THE FUNDING OF
THE APOLLO PROGRAM,
WHAT COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED?
AND WHAT WOULD YOU PRIORITIZE
AS THE TOP OBJECTIVE?"
WE'RE GOING TO THROW
IT TO YOU, NEIL.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
OKAY, SO NOW I WOULDN'T
PRIORITIZE EVERYTHING.
I'D SAY, "MAKE THE WHOLE
SOLAR SYSTEM OUR BACKYARD."
AND IF WE HAD THAT SAME FUNDING,
NASA'S BUDGET WOULD BE
TEN TIMES WHAT IT IS TODAY.
TEN TIMES.
AND AT TEN TIMES, THE WHOLE
SOLAR SYSTEM IS YOUR BACKYARD.
WE'D HAVE CONDOS ON ASTEROIDS.
WE, WELL NO, NO YOU
WOULDN'T WANT TO DO THAT.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: CAN'T,
THEY'RE HARD TO CATCH, YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YOU, NO, I'M JUST SAYING!
YOU, OH, ARE YOU
VACATIONING TO THE MOON?
TO MARS OR BEYOND?
ILIZA SHLESINGER: YOU WANT
TO LIVE IN SPACE SO BAD.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
OH THAT'S HOW.
THAT'S SO, THAT'S SO HOW
IT WOULD BE IF NASA'S BUDGET
WERE TEN TIMES WHAT IT IS?
AND I WOULDN'T PRIORITIZE IT.
LET PEOPLE PRIORITIZE WHERE
THEY WANT TO GO WITH WHATEVER
ROCKETS THEY CHOOSE.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE
DESTINATION AFTER ANOTHER.
LET IT ALL, LET SPACE
BE THE DESTINATION.
MIKE MASSIMINO: NICE, NICE,
UH, I WOULD SAY WE WOULD,
WE WOULD UH,
SEND PEOPLE TO MARS.
AND I THINK ALSO I,
IT WOULD GIVE US UH,
MORE OPPORTUNITY TO FUND SOME
OF THESE COMMERCIAL COMPANIES.
AND GIVE THEM A LITTLE
MORE SEED MONEY.
BECAUSE ONCE WE GET THEM
CREATIVE IN WAYS TO MAKE
MONEY, I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE UH, SOME,
SOME GREAT ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THE SKY IS THE LIMIT.
MIKE MASSIMINO: THE SKY IS
THE LIMIT ONCE THAT HAPPENS.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YOU GOT IT, ALRIGHT,
WHEN STARTALK CONTINUES.
WE'RE GOING TO FEATURE
OUR, OUR REGULAR SEGMENT WITH
BILL NYE THE SCIENCE GUY.
AND WE GET HIS TAKE ON THE
LEGACY OF THE MOON LANDINGS.
WHEN STARTALK CONTINUES.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE].
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
WE'RE BACK ON STARTALK.
FEATURING MY INTERVIEW
WITH APOLLO 11 ASTRONAUT,
BUZZ ALDRIN.
THIS GUY WALKED ON THE MOON.
AND HE'S NOT DONE YET.
HE WANTS US TO GO TO MARS,
AND I HAD TO ASK HIM ABOUT IT,
CHECK IT OUT.
BUZZ ALDRIN:
YOU KNOW WHAT ISRU IS?
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YES, LOVING IT.
BUZZ ALDRIN: YOU DO?
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
IN SITU RESOURCE UTILIZATION.
BUZZ ALDRIN: RIGHT, NOW,
I HAD TO TALK TO THE NEW,
NEW HEAD OF THAT.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: WHICH
IS, WHICH IS FANCY WORD FOR,
WHEN YOU GO THERE YOU CAN'T
BRING ALL YOUR SUPPLIES.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO LIVE
WHEN YOU GET THERE.
EXTRACT WATER FROM THE SOIL.
BUZZ ALDRIN: YEAH,
NOW, IF I WENT TO SAY,
"WHAT IS THE BEST, WHAT
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
THAT WE NEED FOR THE FUTURE?"
ROCKET FUEL.
TO REFUEL ROCKETS
HEADING FOR MARS.
IF YOU CAN'T DO THAT, ALL
OF THAT HAS TO BE LIFTED UP.
OH, IS IT SO MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE IN TIME AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YOU WANT FILLING STATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE SOLAR SYSTEM?
BUZZ ALDRIN: WELL, WE
WANT ONE CERTAINLY WHERE A
FAIR AMOUNT
OF FUEL WE CAN KEEP.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: I
LOVE IT BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
TRY, TYING TO LEAD THE CHARGE.
EVEN THE SHIRT YOUR WEARING.
OKAY, "GET
YOUR ASS TO MARS."
THAT IS A
BRILLIANT SHIRT, BRILLIANT.
I WANT TO BRING THE REST OF
MY BODY AS WELL AS MY ASS.
HE, HE WANTS TO GO
TO MARS SO BADLY,
THAT ANY TIME NASA TALKS ABOUT
GOING TO THE MOON, HE, HE,
HE FIGHTS AGAINST IT.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: EVEN
IF THAT'S LIKE THE NEXT THING
NASA WANTS TO DO,
HE DOESN'T CARE.
HE WANTS TO GO TO MARS.
ALRIGHT, WELL BEFORE WE CLOSE
OUT THIS SHOW, AS ALWAYS WE,
I GOT TO CATCH
UP WITH MY BUDDY,
BILL NYE THE SCIENCE GUY.
AND I'M TOLD HE GAVE HIS
THOUGHTS ON THE APOLLO PROGRAM
WHILE AT THE UN.
AND I SAID WHAT?
WHAT, I HAVEN'T SEEN IT, I
HAVEN'T SEEN IT, I JUST HEARD,
THIS IS A DISPATCH,
NYE TIMES IN THE CITY.
FROM THE UN.
I GOTTA CHECK IT
OUT, LET'S SEE.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
BILL NYE:
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
IN 1967, AS THE RACE
TO THE MOON WAS REALLY
PICKING UP SPEED,
COUNTRIES FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD CAME TOGETHER AND
SIGNED THE OUTER SPACE TREATY.
IN IT, HUMANS FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD AGREED THAT NO
COUNTRY, NO ONE, COULD
LAY CLAIM TO A CELESTIAL BODY
LIKE THE MOON.
AND, AND CLAIM IT FOR
HIS, HER, OR ITSELF.
FURTHERMORE...
THE TREATY HOLDS THAT NO ONE,
OR COUNTRY CAN INTERFERE WITH
ANY LIFE WE MIGHT
FIND OUT THERE.
THIS IS THE "PRIME DIRECTIVE."
I'M SURE YOU OR YOUR FRIENDS
ARE FAMILIAR WITH IT,
IT'S FROM STAR TREK.
CAN'T INTERFERE.
BRILLIANT.
NOW IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
PRIME DIRECTIVE IS EXTRACTED
ENTIRELY FROM THE CHARTER
OF THE UNITED NATIONS.
THEY BOTH SAY LET'S AGREE
TO PREVENT AGGRESSION.
EITHER MILITARY OR BIOLOGICAL.
BUT THE PRIME DIRECTIVE
IS THE SAME IDEA WRIT
ON A COSMIC SCALE.
BACK TO YOU, NEIL.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
COOL, BILL NYE THE SCIENCE GUY.
HOW DID HE GET TO GIVE
A SPEECH AT THE UN?
HOW DID THAT, HOW DID HE?
MIKE MASSIMINO: I
THINK YOU SNEAK IN WHEN NO
ONE ELSE IS AROUND.
ILIZA SHLESINGER: YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THERE'S A BACKDOOR.
MIKE MASSIMINO: I THINK
THAT'S WHAT'S WHAT, YEAH.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
THAT KIND OF...
ILIZA SHLESINGER: SLIP THE
SECURITY GUARD SOMETHING.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
YEAH THEY, DIDN'T SHOW THE,
THEY DIDN'T SHOW THE...
ILIZA SHLESINGER: NO ONE
THERE, HE WENT ON A SUNDAY.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: YEAH,
YEAH, YEAH, WENT ON A SUNDAY.
SO, SO WHAT ARE YOUR
PARTING REFLECTIONS, ILIZA?
ILIZA SHLESINGER: I
THINK WITHOUT DREAMERS,
WE WOULD NEVER GET
TO OUTER SPACE.
SO I THINK THE MORE WE CAN
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO DREAM NO
MATTER HOW SILLY, OR
STUPID, OR INSANE IT SOUNDS,
NOBODY'S CALLED
CRAZY WHEN THEY ACTUALLY
SUCCEED AT SOMETHING.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
ANYONE WHO SUCCEEDS IS
NEVER CALLED CRAZY.
I LIKE THAT.
SO, SO MIKE?
YEAH, GIVE ME SOMETHING.
MIKE MASSIMINO:
I, I THINK IT'S VERY...
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: THE
OLD MAN WHO HAS BEEN IN SPACE.
MIKE MASSIMINO: YEAH.
I, I THINK, I THINK IT'S
GREAT THAT YOU HAD BUZZ ON.
BECAUSE HE'S REALLY
A NATIONAL TREASURE.
TWELVE, ONLY TWELVE PEOPLE
GOT TO WALK ON THE MOON.
UH, SEVEN OF THEM ARE STILL
AROUND, AND IT'S GREAT TO,
TO HAVE HIM
FEATURED LIKE THAT.
UM, WHAT THEY
ACCOMPLISHED WAS GREAT,
BUT IT WAS A BLIP, RIGHT?
IT HAPPENED, IT WAS
A LONG TIME AGO,
WE WENT THERE AND CAME BACK.
AND THE NEXT TIME WE GO,
I THINK WE SHOULD SETTLE
IN A LITTLE MORE.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SETTLE IN.
YOU MEAN UH,
CREATE A MOON COLONY?
MIKE MASSIMINO: CREATE
A COLONY, A SETTLEMENT,
A PLACE TO HANG OUT.
RESEARCH LABORATORY,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
I THINK WE SHOULD
GO AND STAY FOREVER.
DR. NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
SO WHEN I THINK ABOUT ALL
THIS AND REFLECT,
UH I THINK TO MYSELF,
THERE IS AN OUTER SPACE
TREATY FOR THE PEACEFUL USE
OF OUTER SPACE.
SO THE GOAL IS WHEN
WE ALL GO INTO SPACE,
WE WILL TREAT ONE
ANOTHER KINDLY.
AND I DON'T HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE THAT OTHERS
HAVE IN THAT.
I WANT TO BELIEVE IT,
BUT I SAY TO MYSELF IF YOU
CAN TREAT EACH
OTHER KINDLY IN SPACE,
THEN WHY NOT
DO THAT HERE ON EARTH?
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO BE IN
SPACE TO NOT KILL ONE ANOTHER?
HOWEVER, MY ONE
GLIMMER OF HOPE,
IS THAT SO MUCH OF HUMAN
CONFLICT IN THE HISTORY OF
CIVILIZATION HAS BEEN DERIVED
FROM SCARCITY OF RESOURCES,
AND ACCESS TO THOSE RESOURCES.
AND I LOOK AT SPACE.
ASTEROIDS, COMETS.
STARS WITH LIMITLESS
ENERGY, AND I REALIZE,
WE SHOULD ALL REALIZE, THAT
SPACE IS A LIMITLESS SUPPLY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES.
SPACE MAY BE THE ONLY PLACE
WHERE PEACE IS GUARANTEED,
BECAUSE IN FACT, WE WOULD
HAVE RUN OUT OF ALL REASONS
FOR WHY TO KILL ONE ANOTHER.
YOU'VE BEEN WATCHING STARTALK,
HERE AT THE AMERICAN
MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY.
AND I'VE BEEN YOUR HOST,
YOUR PERSONAL ASTROPHYSICIST,
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON.
AND AS ALWAYS, I NOW BID
ALL OF YOU, NOT ONLY FAREWELL,
BUT I REQUIRE IN LIFE
THAT YOU KEEP LOOKING UP.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE].